every now and again you get a celebrity
that gets torn right and uh you know I
haven't said too much about the the
Kanye Hitler stuff we talked about it
like a week or two ago it's also stupid
I think we should just ignore him he's
obviously not well he's surrounded by
really horrible people he has noxious
bad ideas hopefully he will come around
and I think the best way to get people
to come around is for everyone to just
kind of live honestly and forthrightly
and then you know the truth will set you
free kind of thing but Bill Burr you
guys might know comedian Bill Burr uh he
had an incredible take on Kanye this is
from a couple years ago and it's been
making the rounds and I just thought
this was absolutely perfect kind of put
a button on the Kanye thing so we can
just move past it okay next time Kanye's
going off on himself I'm telling you
just close your eyes forget it's him and
really listen to what is coming out of
this guy's mouth
he says [ __ ] like I'm a genius
I'm a God I'm Shakespeare
my biggest regret is I'll never get to
see myself before I'm live
that's a direct quote my biggest regret
is I'll never get to see myself perform
live dude you put that ego in a white
dude that is it benign and it's rising
what's the blitz pink what's the
superior race
Vienna will return to Deutschland first
I mean that's pretty good and that's
from a couple years ago